I'm heading down the Dorset Coast to go
diving one of my all-time favorite foods
gods
those speed cameras here is their backup
I adore scallops and I've stirred them
on all my menus but most of them are
fished in our commercial scale using
dredging which can damage the seabed
the sustainable way to catch them is to
go diving and pick them up by hand which
is what I'm gonna do today hand I've
scalloped especially is something that
is considered a bit of a jewel in the
crown phenomenal I'm off to meet Tom
Whittle in Weymouth who's been diving
for scallops since he was 12
have you got any shoes you have got some
somewhere everywhere right
temperature-wise what's it gonna be like
down there 40 degrees if we're lucky
yeah yeah if we're lucky yeah
seriously see another in abundance it
depends sort of where you go but
normally what you do is basically get
down there and if there's tonnes and you
just work them yeah and if there's none
and you just feel my [ __ ] fur you
fine good really other dangly bits yeah
I've heard that before
we're heading out to the Black Hawk
wreck where we'll start our dive
marine life congregate on Rex and nearby
there's an abundance of scallops
having an average size probably about
that feels pretty cousin up none at the
moment ever getting some South goes down
the west coast but costing about three
pound fifty four pound each each each
such as you sculpt
the reason the hand-dyed scarves are so
expensive is that they are incredibly
hard to catch and a diver will only pick
up a fraction of the hoard of a
commercial fisherman and little to see
army yeah yeah they can be I mean
especially if they've buried themselves
into the sand but it's all about getting
your eye into it yeah why is it like
this when you get to this stage you're
always person for a pee it's the way
that it is it's the rule of the game
unbelievable
you like that [ __ ] condom again yeah
what are these things
visibility down here today is terrible
which makes spotting scallops that are
nestled into the sand almost impossible
elegant isn't it mother
well then you see your quality scallops
Oh lovely right least I'm Tom Norma
saves these scallops for supper what I
want to eat mine straight away the
fresher the better right fantastic
they look amazing but open them and
clean them yeah so let's call up tartar
yeah basically a raw die scallop mixed
with lime
yeah shovel and then a little bit of
creme fraiche and mascarpone cheese yeah
absolutely amazing dive open the scholar
and then eat a look I mean they're still
pulsating now I fell under stall it's
extraordinary
mix some creme fraiche with mascarpone
cheese lime zest lime juice
some chervil and salt and pepper right
dices scallops in and all we do now just
hold that in there so exciting eating
raw scallops so I'm going to serve the
scope tartare inside the lettuce leaf so
just open up the heart of the baby gym
lettuce quite robust leaf this so they
can take this collar
absolutely delicious and there we are a
very simple scallop tartare far away
buddy
Cheers there you go they are so tasty
ah ten times better to use hand-dyed I'm
not drenched and I'd rather pay double
for hand dives yeah
then cheap dread scallops that takes the
grip cheers Cheers
scallops away
I'll tell you this is by far the best
way to bag a decent catch oh [ __ ] me the
big one that beauty lovely